it was an extraordinary end to an
unusual day British Prime Minister Boris
Johnson walked out of the prime minister
of Luxembourg offices just minutes
before the two leaders would do to hold
a press conference a crowd of anti
brexit protesters chanted and booed as
he went left alone of the podium exactly
a battle was visibly frustrated had met
Johnson to discuss brexit but said the
British leader had offered nothing to
convince him and other EU leaders to
reopen the withdrawal agreement for me I
just have one withdrawal agreement on
the table and it's the one from last
year there are no changes there are no
concrete proposals for the moment on the
table and I won't give an agreement two
ideas we need written proposals and the
time is ticking so stop speaking act
Johnson said it left because of the
noisy protests he disagreed with bettle
that no progress had been made on break
suit I think we've got actually just the
right amount of time to do a deal we now
in the 17th 18th of October but as I
never tire of telling you if we can't do
a deal by them and obviously we want to
we're very hard to do
then we'll make sure that we can come
out on the 31st of October Deal or maybe
before his talks with exactly a battle
Boris Johnson had met the head of the
European Commission jean-claude Anka for
a working lunch but it seems that that
meeting didn't go very well either
after the two-hour lunch in a restaurant
the European Commission released a
statement that said the British leader
had failed to offer any new alternatives
to the Irish backstop part of the
withdrawal agreement that Johnson wants
scrapped outside the restaurant pro-eu
demonstrators had gathered many of us
have lived here for many years but we
are still deeply concerned by what he's
currently happening in the UK and what
potentially a No Deal exit from the EU
will mean for the country disaster it
will be disaster for Great Britain and
as a whole the two sides did agree to
continue and intensify talks
Janka said that Europe never loses
patience but the day's events suggests
that the ease goodwill could be running
out Natasha Butler al Jazeera Luxembourg